Flughunde nutzen zur Fortbewegung einen außergewöhnlichen
Bewegungsapparat.
Der besteht aus einer elastischen Haut, die
sich von den Fingerknochen bis zu den Zehen
spannt.
Ein deutsches Technologieunternehmen hat nun
einen von der Natur inspirierten Flugapparat
gebaut.
Diese bionische Konstruktion hat eine Spannweite
von 2 Metern 28, bringt aber nur 580 Gramm
auf die Waage.
Kleine Motoren im Rumpf ermöglichen, jeden
Flüge einzeln einzustellen.
Ein größerer Motor sorgt für das Flügelschlagen
selbst.
Das macht das Fluggerät sehr wendig.
Zwar klappen Start und Landung noch nicht
ohne die Hilfe der Konstrukteure - im Flug
aber ist der künstliche Flughund semi-autonom.
In einem vorgegebenen Radius navigiert der
Apparat mittels einer Anreihung von Kameras
selbstständig.
Der bionische Flughund soll der Öffentlichkeit
auf der Hannover Messe Ende April vorgestellt
werden.